Speaker 1: It is great to have back on
the program. A Zarian, who's a cognitive
neuroscientist, blogger for Psychology Today
and whose new book is The Romance of Reality
How the Universe Organizes Itself to Create
Life, Consciousness and Cosmic Complexity.
Bobby, great to speaking to you again.
Speaker 6: Thanks for having me back, David.
Speaker 1: So, I mean, the book is fascinating
because it starts with these are just big topics,
right? How what what are the origins of life?
What is what is consciousness? What is sort of
our place? How do we understand our ability
to perceive and understand? But it also has
very much real world kind of day to day nitty
gritty implications about how we solve individual
problems, political questions, how people relate
to each other, how we understand what is real and
what is not real and kind of epistemology. Can you
talk just like generally what what was the main
point you wanted to get across in the book?
Speaker 6: So yeah, there are a lot of
points that you mentioned, but the general idea
is that. So it's, I guess to contrast it to the
old paradigm. The old paradigm, the kind of
reigning scientific worldview was known as
the reductionist paradigm. And it basically says
that life is something of a cosmic accident and
that life is transient and has no larger cosmic
significance. But the story that's emerging from
complexity science is challenging, that basically
says that the universe isn't getting increasingly
disordered as once thought, it's getting more
and more complex. And life is a part of that
complex ification process. And once life emerges,
it becomes the driver of that process. So we're
not an accident. We are a natural manifestation of
the laws of physics and the evolutionary dynamics
that emerge from those laws. And this means that
life has something like a purpose in the universe,
and that's to see that life continues to
persist and spread throughout the cosmos.
Speaker 1: What's fascinating about that, to
put a pause there, is if people listen to 90%
but not 100% of what you're saying, they might
misunderstand what you're saying as meaning
either one, that there is purpose in the
way that some attribute to religion or God,
which is not what you're saying here. You're
saying that the purpose of life is is to persist.
Life wants to continue so so to speak. And number
two, if people listen to 90%, but not 100% of what
you're saying, they might think you're saying that
the preexisting ideas, for example, about entropy
are being contradicted by what you're saying,
but you're not really you're sort of expanding
on that in a sense, if I understand correctly.
Speaker 6: Yes. So to address those two points,
let's start with the entropy point first. There's
a lot of confusion about what the second law
of thermodynamics means. Yes. And there's a
statistical interpretation of that law that
basically says that ordered systems will naturally
move toward a more disordered state, and that
that's true for closed systems. So closed systems
are systems that aren't open to energy coming in
from an outside source. So the planet Earth is an
open system, and that is because we have a star,
we have our sun that is radiating all of this
energy down on the planet. And those energy flows
basically organize life. And we so energy flowing
through a simple chemical system will organize it.
And that is the mechanism that creates life on
a planet. So the idea basically is that life can
continue to persist against this tendency towards
disorder as long as it can continue to extract
energy from the environment because the energy is
used to sustain itself. But in using that energy,
it uses up ordered energy and it dissipates that
energy as heat, and that creates entropy too.
So complexity can grow and grow and grow
if life can spread and find more energy.
And the second law of thermodynamics really just
says that there's an energetic cost to creating
order, that you have to use some of this available
energy and basically turn that energy into entropy
so it doesn't violate the second law unless
you think the second law applies to the whole
universe and says that the universe is growing
increasingly disordered. This challenges that and
says we need to understand that entropy is this
complex term. It takes on a number of forms and
that life doesn't have to be transient.
If we can solve our problems and continue
to extract energy, then we can persist.
Speaker 1: The religious purpose that is
often debated by Christian apologists and others.
You're talking about purpose in a different way,
and it makes intuitive sense if you think about,
for example, evolution, right? And the idea well,
when we when we talk about purpose, you could say
the purpose here is evolution is fueling more fit
species so that they can continue to live so
that life persists. As you're talking about,
we don't have to talk about purpose
ideologically necessarily or as a
designed thing and still acknowledge that
maybe purpose could be an appropriate word
in terms of life wanting to preserve and continue.
Speaker 6: Yes. So there was a big movement to
kind of get purpose. Out of biology in the
20th century. Right. But where understanding
that purpose or agency is really the defining
characteristic of life. So if you compare life
to an inanimate object, like a rock or a chair,
those things don't do anything interesting. And if
they move, if Iraq, you know, tumbles down a hill,
it's because of the force of gravity. Or if you
see Iraq moving on the street, it's being pushed
by a gust of wind. But life moves according to
survival goals. So it has agency. And this agency
is basically a product of the information stored
in living systems, which are adaptive systems.
So it's really helpful to talk about purpose.
But if you zoom out and you look at the universe
and you understand that life isn't any sort of
magical, it doesn't have some sort of magical
ingredient propelling it. Then you see that
the inanimate matter in the universe is waking
up in the form of life. And so you don't see it
so much as just life trying to persist. You see it
as the universe sort of waking up through life and
being able to experience itself. So there are some
big what I would call spiritual implications of
this theory, but it is an entirely mechanistic,
naturalistic picture because we can understand
these processes that generate complexity.
We can formalize them with mathematics. So
there's no magic in this framework. However, I
will say it is still really mysterious why the
universe is so fine tuned to give rise to life.
And if you believe the argument in this book,
it doesn't just allow life. It necessitates
life and basically ensures that life will
continue to adapt and spread.
Speaker 1: So along those lines,
when we look at societies and the way that
human society is organized, we can find lots of
relatively persistent. You know, I'm talking
here about hundreds of years, which is still a
relatively small amount of time. But but in modern
society, we see lots of mechanisms that seem like
they would run counter to that. Right. World
Wars, for example, the seeking and obtaining
of nuclear weapons, which, you know, it's hard to
argue that nuclear weapons in some longterm way
will preserve life. They seem only only able to
potentially destroyed or at best do nothing at all
conflict. So we what is the role at the sort of
more medium term society level of some of these
systems that seem to run very contrary to to life?
Speaker 6: So there's a principle in the book
that I call Popper's principle, named after
the philosopher of science, Karl Popper. And it
basically says that problems create progress. So
you mentioned World War Two, and it was a terrible
time. A lot of bad things happened, but that same
time period produced the computer and information
technology, and the computer was kind of a need
to do a couple of things. People have seen a movie
about Alan Turing where the computer was used to
crack Enigma, the Nazi code. Yep. And the computer
was also used to try to create nuclear weapons by
von Neumann and others. So you do get this kind
of paradoxical thing where you have technology
that has terrible uses and really good uses.
So it does seem a little bit contradictory,
but not when you realize that it's the problems
that we face that pushes us to find solutions
and pushes us in the direction of progress.
Mass extinctions. Basically, if you look at the
trend as far as like biological complexity and
diversity, after every mass extinction, the
biosphere went to new levels of complexity
and diversity. So it's like life adapts and
evolves and evolves because it has challenges. So
this will lead people to kind of question this
idea of progress because they see all these things
going on, these mounting existential challenges
like climate change and the threat of nuclear war,
rising income inequality. But it is
precisely those challenges that push us to
find solutions that ultimately lead to progress.
Speaker 1: Now, that doesn't mean we ignore the
like. So for example, someone might hear that
and say. Hey, listen, based on what Bobby said,
we just shouldn't worry about climate
change, because no matter even if it is
as destructive as the worst hypotheses say it is,
eventually life will persist and things will just
kind of like reorder themselves and everything
will be okay. But it sounds like what you're
saying is these are opportunities for humans
to do things and to figure out solutions.
Speaker 6: Yes. So that thing that you
said earlier would be like the the worst way to
interpret this. Yes. We can't the process doesn't
happen on its own. And it goes back to the point
that we're part of this process. Yes. So we need
to try our very best to overcome these solutions.
If not, we will be the errors that get corrected
by natural selection and the people who come after
us or the, you know, species or civilization that
comes after us will do something different.
Hopefully they'll learn from our mistakes.
But yeah, it's this process of continually
learning from failure. Right. And yeah, we.
We have to do everything in our power to overcome
these existential challenges. And one thing that
this theory kind of shows about society is that
societies work in a very similar way as organism
organisms, biological organisms. So you are an
organism, and you usually think about that as
being one single thing. But you're a collective of
cells, right? At working together in an integrated
fashion. Your brain is a collection of 80 billion
neurons, all connected by 10,000 connections each.
And the output of that collective computation is
your intelligent behavior and your productivity.
So you can look at a society as being a social
organism, and you can even look at the network
of humans that spans the planet as forming
something like a global brain because of the
Internet and social media, and now blockchain
systems connecting us in a very similar way.
And if we want to overcome our existential
challenges, we have to use the full computational
power of the global brain. And this gives us
some principles for how to optimize our social,
political and economic systems.
Speaker 1: So on that note,
in the limited time we have left all of this, if
we go down to the kind of like the nitty gritty
level. What are the immediate things that in
human society could be done, as you see it,
to better orient ourselves towards this future?
And this could be regulating social media,
passing some laws about carbon. I mean, like if we
just were to say what what are the bullet points
of things that could be done by governments
and organizations at this point to better
serve our future? Is there a sort of short list?
Speaker 6: Yes. There's a long list and a short
list. So everything that, you know, people are
fighting for right now, those are, you know,
worthy things that we should be tackling. But
there are some more basic principles that come
from complexity science, which just tells us
how to get the maximum amount of computational
power out of a system. So computational power
is a function of how complex a system is.
A system is more complex if there are more
components and there are more connections
between those components. And you also want
a variety of different types of components.
So we want to be connected in a way similar to how
neurons are connected in the brain. So any nation
that cuts their people off from the Internet
is stopping that free flow of information.
And the free the free flow of information
allows for greater social awareness and
knowledge exchange. So, you know, countries like
North Korea, Russia, China that are doing that,
that's not intrinsically good for a complex
adaptive system in the long run. The other
thing I mentioned was the need for diversity
among components. So the human body has over 200
cell types because they're doing a division
of labor, a society of all doctors or society
of all engineers or musicians wouldn't do well.
So we need specialization because it allows for
a division of labor and we so we need diversity
and not just cultural diversity, but a diversity
of ideas. So any system, any nation that doesn't
allow for criticism of the current system,
that's also intrinsically bad because you
want new ideas that challenge the status quo.
That's sort of how progress happens to the last
thing that I would say is income inequality.
So we're seeing levels of income inequality higher
than we've ever seen before, and that means all of
the resources are concentrated in these small
pockets. So that would be so if society is a
social organism that would be like all of the
resources, like the blood, the nutrients, all in
certain areas and not systemically flowing right
to all the appendages. And if that is the case,
then ultimately that super organism will die
because those parts will fester and then affect
the rest of the body. So we want to have a way
to kind of redistribute these resources. I don't
think like a communist model or like a socialist
model is necessarily the best way to do that
because you don't want like a government
with all this power, like calling the shots,
you want some sort of natural way to do that.
And I think the decentralization movement made
popular by cryptocurrencies and Bitcoin is a
way to do that because Nfts will allow for a
new crowdfunding mechanism that will allow, you
know, normal people to raise money for a business
project. And then the people who are donating to
that project, like they would Kickstarter, they
actually become investors, right? So there's a lot
of creative ways, you know, and to think about how
to structure society, maybe we need some optimal
balance between socialist and capitalist policies.
Decentralization could provide, you know,
new ideas about how to find that balance.
But yeah, we need to look at how nature has
optimized systems through evolutionary processes
to kind of teach us how to best optimize society.
Speaker 1: We've been speaking with cognitive
neuroscientist and blogger Bobby Azari, and
the new book is The Romance of Reality How
the Universe Organizes Itself to Create
Life Consciousness in Cosmic Complexity.
Bobby, always a pleasure having you on.
Speaker 6: Thank you so much, David,
and congratulations on being a new father.
Speaker 1: Thank you.